les images des plages bondées de
copacabana et ipanema après le
déconfinement ont fait bondir marcelo
krivets la face à ce relâchement
le maire de rio dé janeiro a fait marche
arrière
l'édile a annoncé qu'il ne rouvrirait
les plages au public que lorsqu'il
aurait un vaccin contre le coronavirus
les contrevenants sont passibles d'une
amende d'environ 20 euros
pourtant de nombreux touristes
brésiliens ne veulent pas renoncer à
leur bronzage
le confinement ici a toujours été
quelque chose de très confus le
gouverneur de rio veut tous fermés bref
cela ouvre tout rouvrir il défend
l'utilisation de la chloroquine c'est
une bataille de discours politique et
personne ne veut se mettre d'accord
vanderley silva et vendeurs de chips sur
la plage de copacabana depuis dix ans
les plages de rio dé janeiro est enfermé
depuis mars il a perdu sa source de
revenus du jour au lendemain une mesure
difficile pour lui les 40 millions de
travailleurs informels du brésil si
c'est le mieux à faire pour freiner la
pandémie qu on ferme tout qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire d'autre
si j'avais le choix - si j'aurais
préféré être chez moi plutôt que de
venir travailler car la vie est beaucoup
plus importante que l'argent dans les
rues de la capitale touristique
l'épidémie semble pourtant lointaine
tout comme les kiosques sur les plages
paradisiaques de rio dé janeiro les bars
restaurants et cafés ont pu rouvrir
le tout en respectant des mesures
strictes de distanciation des
restrictions qui ne sont pas toujours
respectées à orca le célèbre quartier du
pain de sucre
la police surveille le flux dans les
bars pour empêcher les clients de
s'agglutiner je ne pense pas que
l'ouverture des commerces non essentiels
et prématurés y était temps car cela
sauf des millions d'emplois et de toute
façon les cas à rio seront en train de
diminuer
je pense que le gouvernement a raison il
faut surveiller si l'accord ne mentons
sera obligé de tout fermer de nouveau
les médecins et les autorités sanitaires
brésiliennes s'inquiète à l'image de
roberto mais dronneau pour le directeur
de recherche de l'hôpital universitaire
de rio dé janeiro la rouverture des
services non essentiels ne devrait pas
se faire tant qu un confinement
de plus de 30 jours n'aura pas été
appliquée dans tout le pays
cela fait plus de cent jours que les
brésiliens sont confinés nous battons
peut-être des records mondiaux mais le
confinement n'a jamais été strict au
brésil comme cela a été le cas en france
ici à rio même si les cas diminue petit
à petit le nombre de cas de
contamination est encore énorme et nous
sommes en train de rouvrir les services
non essentiels dans quelques jours nous
aurons certainement une augmentation du
nombre de cas deuxième pays le plus
touché par la pandémie de coronavirus le
brésil continue d'attendre un remède
deux des vaccins dont l'élaboration la
plus avancée dans le monde doivent être
testés sur plusieurs milliers de
volontaires brésilien les prévisions les
plus optimistes tablent sur une
homologation d'ici la fin de l'année et
des vaccinations début 2021